hello some of you may have if you saw
this talk last year it's the same talk
so you don't have to stay if you they
were kind enough let me do it again
because it went pretty well last year
and it's got good information so but if
you did see it last year it is the same
general idea there's a couple new
innovations that I brought with me that
I'll be able to share and this is not a
dotnet talk or a Microsoft talk this is
to talk about my open source artificial
pancreas people sometimes laugh when I
say that but it is a real thing I've
been I've been using an open source
artificial pancreas for over two years
almost three it's a very new thing and I
do not take credit for any of this other
than being a member of the community and
there's no one person that can take
credit for this
it's libraries and innovations and
moments of technology that have all been
brought together by a number of
community leaders and there's now in
fact choice in artificial pancreas as
there's three or four different
pancreases you can choose from depending
on your needs this is pretty interesting
I have been diabetic type 1 diabetic for
25 years any type one diabetics in the
room
we're guy right here everybody else this
shoe that's unusual for a group that's
large they even a pump or pens pens
okay I'm gonna use you later as an
example listen to my podcast it's very
good I worked very hard on it and it's
uh it's been around for a very long time
I had this fellow on he's a doctor doing
research into Bionic he called them
Bionic pancreas I talked to him in 2014
smart fella but nobody's selling these
yet it's been five years and that's kind
of an interesting thing that I talked to
this gentleman in 2014 it's 2019 and
here we are and where's my where's my
jetpack
it's not that it's not always the way
I'm a diabetic for a quarter of a
century and they have been telling me
every year that in five years they would
cure it so we got tired of waiting
so we figured we'd do it ourselves um
usually when you do a talk like this
about health usually put a picture of
yourself doing something fit this is not
me I don't know who this guy is I don't
know what his deal is or what he's
trying to accomplish I don't know who's
taking the picture or who thought that
was a good idea most of my exercise
injuries are mostly Netflix related
again that's me I've written about
diabetes for many years on my blog
techniques ways to hack your body let me
give you some basics of type 1 diabetes
if there's any type ones or your
gentlemen over here or any type twos
that disagree it's a open forum we
should talk about it if I
mischaracterized some aspect of diabetes
that you feel that I got wrong
definitely speak up because we want to
make sure we get it right but type ones
are not type twos and this is an
unfortunate thing because type one
diabetes and type 2 diabetes sound like
the same thing like there's different
flavors or the same thing they're just
two different kind of sugar metabolism
related diseases they're so different
they really should be called something
something else the type 1 diabetes means
that my pancreas makes no insulin I
produce zero insulin if you give me a
bunch of sugar I can't process it I
can't do anything with it and I'll
eventually die so I have to put insulin
in me I have to replace what I cannot
make myself type 2 diabetes is a much
more complicated thing that you often
see in elderly folks or people who are
of a certain size or have got a genetic
makeup that is causing them to use the
insulin that they do make in effectively
so they make insulin they just don't
either make enough or they don't use it
very effectively and often they are
prescribed pills or you know work out
eat less carbs type of a thing often
times I'll post something about type 1
diabetes which is not something I can
cure and very well-meaning people from
cultures all over the world will suggest
air Vedic this or hope yoga that or
stress this or these are all useful tech
they will improve my diabetes but they
can't cheer it so it's like particularly
with art with our friends in India
there's a lot of herbs and things that
you can use to improve diabetes largely
those are targeted towards type 2
diabetes they will allow you to use your
insulin more effectively they will allow
you to reduce stress reduce inflammation
all these things are positive things but
I need you to understand if you are
gonna email me afterwards about how I
should use some herbs and spices that I
literally make no insulin so I would
need to use a combination of stress
techniques and things like that and tea
and whatnot and also some insulin I have
found personally that when I used more
Eastern medicines I can lower the amount
of insulin I use which means I'm being
more effective it's like I got a
headache I can take five ibuprofen or I
can do some breathing exercises and take
one so it's that kind of a thing so the
analogy that we like to use when we
explain diabetes is this airplane
analogy now this is a simple this is an
oversimplified thing so if anyone here
is doing research in the space or is a
PhD I gave a talk at the Open University
earlier this week and it turns out half
the room had PhDs and they felt that I
had oversimplified things but for a
layperson audience yes I'm gonna
oversimplify things okay food raises
blood sugar anything that you eat goes
into your body and it turns into sugar
if you eat sugar it turns into sugar if
you eat meat it turns into sugar
everything turns into glucose and
glucose sits in your bloodstream and it
needs to then be delivered so you eat
some stuff it turns into sugar it's in
your bloodstream and it's ready to be
delivered to the cells insulin opens the
doors of the hallways and allows the
sugar to exit the blood vessels and
enter the cells it unlocks the door in
the cell and says okay I can be
delivered high blood sugar means that
I've got I'm basically marinating in my
own sugar this is a real thing if you've
ever have any grandparents or not has
any relatives that have diabetes you can
smell it on them it's in their breath
it's in their eyes it's in it they they
are steep
in sugar when they pee it stinks because
they're just try the body just needs to
get the sugar out through their breath
through their tongues to their sweat you
are you are literally marinating in your
own sugar until you die
that's called high blood sugar because
the sugars is sitting in the blood
undelivered injected insulin lowers
blood sugar it doesn't really it
delivers blood sugar thereby using it
and they're there for the average amount
of sugar in your blood is lowered it
delivers it to the cells if you take if
you take too much insulin you will
remove all of the fuel from the fuel
lines and then your car will sputter you
won't have enough fuel to run your brain
and you'll pass out I have an insulin
pump plugged into me it's plugged in
here 24 hours a day I sleep with it I
put it behind the pillow I remember when
I'm sleeping not to rotate twice in any
one direction lest I die and then I have
a implant that is a battery that does
bluetooth that looks at my blood sugar
these are from two different companies
and we'll talk about the details of
those things all of these things work to
get insulin into me to keep me alive
what is the goal my goal is to not die
of this success for a diabetic is dying
of anything else ideally I would get hit
by an ice cream truck I think that would
be a very sweet irony
unfortunately diabetics die of diabetes
number one cause of blindness number one
cause of kidney failure number one cause
of amputation whywould was a weird thing
blood sugar why are we losing feet why's
grandma and people losing their toes
they literally chop the toes then the
feet then the legs and they move their
way up you go blind and then you die
again an oversimplification do you have
here these these little honey bears
they're like a squeezy bear you put in
your tea to get the honey
you know it's like a rubber it's like a
plastic bear and there's honey in it and
you squeeze it and you put in your tea
you know the top of that where the honey
gets around the edges it gets all gross
and crystallized and you have to kind of
clean it off any kind of a sugar jams
jellies to get that crystallized gross
sugary stuff that kind of grows imagine
that in your veins where are the little
veins toes eyes fingertips if it gets
clogged filled coated in sugar then
things won't be able to energy will not
be able to get to them so then they die
they die a little bit at a time your
nerves die so that you can't feel your
toes you don't know it you just you've
toes numb then you stub your toe you get
an infection you don't know you have an
infection your toad eyes your foot turns
black and then they chop it off and then
it goes like that
that's why diabetics go blind and why
they're they lose their their
extremities so it kind of sucks highs
will kill you slow much like flying an
airplane if you continue to raise your
altitude you'll eventually go into the
stratosphere and die slowly
lows much with flying will kill you
quick
if you hit zero altitude depending on
your slope you will you will die if I
remove too much insulin then I will have
a seizure or coma and if with a high
though it'll kill you over a year that's
really sucks and some of us have seen
our relatives either die or suffer with
diabetes my situation is such that I
look at this CGM continuous glucose
meter it's sitting in my arm and it
gives me a trendline it gives me a sense
of what my blood sugar is but it's not
100% accurate because it's not really
testing blood it's testing interstitial
fluid
we're just big meat bags right we're
just big old bags and meet with juice in
them and about 70 percent of us as water
so it's looking at the fluid in the
interstitial area between the the skin
and the fat and the muscles and it's
looking at that and it's doing an
electrical signal and looking at the
resistance across that space and
determining and I think your blood
Sugar's about this but I can't be sure
so I have to prick my fingers and look
at real blood whole blood as opposed to
fluid and determine what my blood sugar
is then I have to count carbs do math
diabetics are really good at math and we
calculate how much insulin to take then
I listen to my body and I wonder if this
number lied to me or this number lied to
me or maybe I'm feeling sick or maybe
it's humid or maybe I'm stressed or
traveling or the time zones are wrong or
maybe they gave me a regular coke and
not a Coke Zero and then I loop again
the loop is closed by me inputs and I
make the decision and my blood sugar
looks like that
it's totally chaos for you all y'all
except this gentleman who's now my new
friend we're gonna call you the normals
you're the normally sugared you wake up
in the morning do it over the hell you
want and wake up with great blood sugar
and then you eat whatever and then you
go to sleep and you have to get blood
sugar in your blood so it looks like
that and we're not bitter at all
I've got I have friends who've known me
for 25 years Nago hey would you like a
cookie oh I'm sorry I said cookie and
then they'll just eat the cookie in
front of you you know thank you for that
painful reminder of a Rob Connor he
comes up earlier he's got like a big old
piece of cake with frosting and I was
ago did you bring me cake and frosting
he's like no and he proceeds to eat it
right there so you get a diagnosis how
long have you been diabetic sir okay ten
years tell me this is true every
diabetic engineer every always get
diagnosed and you go this sucks
you freaked out and you're like all
right I'm gonna write some code to fix
it I did it in Excel I went and tried to
psyche and fix this I just need a really
good spreadsheet and and I checked my
blood sugar and I made a whole system
and I wrote code to solve it for every
diabetic engineer thinks that they can
solve this so I did this 20 plus years
ago I wrote glue copilot for the Palm
Pilot and I hooked up blood sugar meters
and serial ports and I downloaded data
into this thing and then I upgraded it
to color Retina display 160 by 160 it's
pretty fantastic stuff
ah and I was uploading it with FTP comma
separated values to my doctor 20 years
ago but there wasn't really a social web
at this time I could go on CompuServe
but who am I gonna talk to you about
this stuff was a very lonely time to
have any disease now I'm just talking
about diabetes but everybody who's got
something you got to find your tribe so
that you can realize that life sucks for
everybody all right otherwise this is
very lonely especially for diabetic kids
so I would hook it up to a modem and I
would send it that 9600 bps up into the
cloud and I would manage it I was very
proud of this I wrote all of this and
sea and metro works now it's good times
how did I get the data from the blood
sugar meter though that was very
frustrating because every company had a
different standard they had a different
adapter and they sometimes encrypted the
data on the serial port it's my blood
sugar why are you making me use your app
to give my blood sugar
that was obnoxious you have to buy their
port to buy their software because you
could apparently hurt yourself with your
own data we are still now struggling to
get a hold of our own data so I said I'm
gonna start writing meter downloaders
remember coding for fun this is 2007 12
years ago I wrote a WinForms app to
download data from a freestyle glucose
meter and we would listen in on the
serial port and try to figure out what
was going on so we could break in to
these things imagine breaking into a
device that holds your data I mean it's
just ridiculous it's like breaking into
the hotel safe not that I did that
earlier but I'm just throwing that out
there
all the while I'm doing this without the
social web without social media without
blogs I'm realizing that other people
are doing this - these are PhDs at a
university and they're figuring out how
to put a blood-sugar meter into a Palm
Pilot
that'd be awesome you talk about all the
cool features you want with the notch
and whatnot on an iPhone I just want a
blood sugar meter at the bottom that
would be the ultimate iPhone for me
people would build these ridiculous Rube
Goldberg II and solutions who Rube
Goldberg is that's the thing where you
put the marble and the marble slides and
then it knocks the bowling ball and then
it Fenton hits the iron and the iron
Smith and then the thing of it that they
would build these solutions that were
like alright well here's my solution on
reddit yeah I send a text to IFTTT with
a number and then it goes into a Google
Drive spreadsheet and then that kicks
off a script and they build these
systems and that's okay because that's
every diabetic engineer always it's just
that they're not really robust they're
not really reliable and they're very
personalized it's a custom workflow now
how are we gonna get this into our
bodies for a long time we boiled needles
big fat multi gauge in high gauge
needles you boil them you'd have one or
two needles they look like the heroin
needles you'd see in the 1920s you know
in a leather kit that's how they got
insulin and they would take
pigs and they would grind up their
pancreas --es and they would try to get
the insulin out of the pig and they
would have beef and cow insulin and in
the 80s they made human insulin and
they've been trying to speed up insulin
insulin usually gets excrete excreted
into your system from the peritoneum and
it's already in your body when it gets
made but we have to get it into the body
you have to puncture the skin and shove
it into the fat but fat is not really
good at absorbing insulin if you eat a
cookie your blood sugar will go up and
immediately down because your body made
insulin right away with me I need to
wait 15 to 45 minutes before the fat
absorbs the insulin that I'm shoving in
so sometimes I have to take insulin
ahead of time in anticipation of a
future cookie like I'm gonna eat a
cookie and ever one's eating their
cookie I'm gonna eat a cookie to take
some insulin and I sit there and I wait
a half an hour and then I eat the cookie
because I need the curve of the sugar
and the cookie to match the curve of the
insulin that's waiting for it so needles
suck so if someone said let's just make
a pump now to the gentleman over here he
uses pens pens are really cool they are
basically in the old days I used to have
a needle a syringe and a thing and I'd
mix the insulin it would be a whole deal
now they have like pens that look like
little pocket flashlights and they have
the needle the insulin and you turn a
knob and you go and then you put it back
in your pocket it's a very very clean
system but the resolution is not very
high and I'll talk about that in a
second so maybe we can make a pump so
DIY to the rescue here's the first
insulin pump
we laughing at my pain that's legit like
he's like God an IV going here and he's
ready to go and run around in his
insulin pump that's the first pump this
gentleman here I'm gonna zoom in on that
that is a if you look closer it's a
photocopy this is the syringe inside of
a carved wooden pump you see this line
right here and then there's the plunger
that's a piece of metal a screw turns
and as a screw turns it gets smaller
because it's screwing into another nut
and it pulls this screw turns and it
pulls that that syringe plunger down
thereby delivering the insulin it would
do one unit per click and it would hold
about 40 units so about one day's worth
of insulin and the resolution is one
unit which is like a teardrop worth of
insulin the gentleman uses pens his pan
will do about a half a unit a click is
that correct
just want you usually just do I won't
you ever do like one and a half a two
and a third just one so he's going by
one as well
some of the newer newer ones will do a
half a unit the insulin pump that I have
will do a tenth of a unit little kids
ones will do twentieths of units because
you really need to think about that in
the context of the airplane are we gonna
be going as we fly this airplane are we
gonna try to make little tiny movements
now back to that airplane analogy you're
gonna go and fly from New York to LA or
call the way across America that's your
day you'd like that to be a nice smooth
flight the whole way you want to look at
the altitude the altimeter multiple
times and you want to make small
adjustments with your your yoke your
joystick you pull up eat some food blood
sugar goes up push forward blood sugar
goes down if you prick your finger it
hurts every time I've been doing it for
25 years where it's every single time
people
has asked me is it always hurt yes it's
a needle quick always like you get used
to that no it's a needle like you get
used to a pin you have paper cuts right
you get used to a paper cut no it's
always a paper cut it's always painful
so most people who prick their fingers
do it about 10 times a day
5 is average 10 would be like any more
than that would be annoying so you're
flying from New York to LA you only get
to look at the altitude 10 times so pick
the right 10 okay and you only get to
touch the joystick as many times as
you're willing to eat to go up or do pen
shots the gentleman could probably do
how many times you should take a shot so
he takes five that's a great number
that's very high for a pen person some
pen people are just like morning lunch
and that's it like you know it's very
simple
he's got five so his resolution is look
at his blood sugar ten times take a pen
five times so he gets to touch the
joystick five times and he gets to look
at the altitude ten times it's still
gonna be a somewhat jerky flight across
the US what we really need is increased
resolution what if I could check my
blood sugar every five minutes and I
could deliver blood sugar David Billa
deliver insulin every five minutes and
rather than making big jerky moves I
could do that thing that we already do
when we're trying to keep the car in the
lines just go like that right that's the
goal but I can't look at my blood sugar
every five minutes I'd go nuts how do we
measure more often well this came out a
while back it's called the gluco watch
we're trying to do non-invasive ways
nobody wants to put a needle in their
body needles suck so they came up with
this idea to take two metallic pads and
put it on your skin and then give you an
electric shock and go across at the
resistance across that shock as they
looked at he at the resistance across
the interstitial fluid to figure out
they could figure out your blood sugar
and it would cause burns so when you
would call them and say hey it really
burns it's getting a very major skin
irritation they say yeah I just rotate
it on the inside and then switch to the
other wrist giving this wrist chance to
heal as you've got
four sides yeah they're not in business
anymore but it they meant well didn't
they right they were trying so what
we're using now for a CGM or a
continuous glucose meter is usually a
thing called a Dexcom where this is the
scary inserter it's a little needle it's
a needle in there right here and that
needle has a tube around it so you stab
yourself with the needle and then you
pull the needle out leaving the tube
that was around the needle in you and
that looks like this it's a little steel
Deeley so that's in my arm now and it
stays in there for anywhere from a week
to 21 days it doesn't hurt though
because it's very small and it's kind of
like sipping and checking and figuring
out what blood sugar is and then it
talks to the battery looks like this
I brought by the way all these things up
front so you can come and see them and
it sits wherever you need to put it
anywhere you've got an inch to pinch you
can put this can be on the tushie you
can be in the up here I put mine in my
arm I move them around
I move this every week to three weeks
depending I'll tell you about that in a
second and that tells me what my blood
sugar is so that's that's from an
engineering perspective that's the read
it is read only every five minutes but
it's not whole blood it's fluid so it's
plus or minus ten 20 percent correct
sometimes it's right sometimes totally
wrong then on the right we need to
deliver insulin we put a tube in the
skin into the fat and then the pump just
like we saw with that wooden pump has a
screw that turns that then pushes the
insulin through the flexible tubing and
then the loop is read your blood sugar
think about it do what you're going to
do and then deliver the insulin nothing
is automatic if I'm going to have a
cookie I think about it I do a bunch of
math and I say well it's got 30
the carbs and that that and I'm my ratio
is one unit of insulin per 15 grams of
carbs so it's a two carb thing but my
blood sugar is already low so I should
use a unit and you have 42 different
factors from the humidity to how you're
feeling to whether or not you get the
flu I love that you're nodding it makes
me feel very safe thank you for that
this is all these things and it's not
automatic and we always there oh this
just does everything for you right no it
does nothing there's nothing for you it
is delivery only delivery that's it this
is what it looks like if you are a
supermodel who does not have diabetes
and you've been hired and you've been
hired to show what it looks like
the reality is bruises and holes and
lumpy bits and fat that has become lumpy
because it can no longer absorb insulin
because it's been abused over 20 years
you'll put one hole in you as you heal
another sometimes you'll hit a gusher we
go hit a vein or an artery that's a
little bit higher in the skin so you'd
be like oh this is a good spot you hit
it and it's just blood everywhere so
it's not definitely for the faint of
heart and it looks nothing like that and
no one's belly button looks like that
but we have the Reed and then the right
okay yeah and you have to move it around
and they can't be near each other
because that's putting insulin in the
fat and that's sucking it out sucking
out the data if they were near each
other they would interfere so I have to
keep things on different sides of the
body and I have to rotate them always
looking for spots that I haven't abused
I'm not this guy though this is Chris
Dancy and he is in the quantified
self-movement what he does is put as
many sensors on his body as possible to
develop a sixth sense he wants to know
about his blood pressure about his heart
rate but is sugar all these things all I
care about is sugar but what's
interesting about the quantified self
and the people who live within it is
that they believe that you do develop a
sense I know what my blood sugar is
mostly because I have for multiple times
a day for decades felt some kind of way
and looked at a number and now I have a
number that means this is what it feels
like when that number happens so that my
wife will say what's your blood sugar my
god I'm about 130 right now we use
different numbers in the US and I'll
look and it'll all be confirmed right
just like you know about how fast the
car is going plus or minus 20 kilometers
an hour right we need this data I want
to be able to store it somewhere I won't
be able to access it I wrote an article
in 2001 almost 18 years ago this is this
is this is young Scott the pump might
use my cell phone to call its data into
a central server
maybe if I wander near my home computer
the pump could take the opportunity to
upload its data bluetooths
third Bluetooth was just coming out
bluetooth 30 meter range no meter and a
half tops could provide my doctor with
my medical history as I sit in the
waiting room like I had this image of
these connected systems 20 years ago I
wrote this on my blog my wife and I went
around and we managed it on a Palm Pilot
and a laptop in the hotel it is it is a
complicated thing
so there's a community of people who
have decided that this is problematic
and they've decided we're not waiting
I got we got tired of waiting so that's
our hashtag we are not waiting and
there's a foundation called the night
Scout foundation that allows us to
unlock our data particularly from things
like continuous glucose meters and store
it in an open source system it's built
on node runs on Heroku and azure stores
the data in and it lets you see
your blood sugar in real time so for
example that's my blood sugar right now
please don't spread the URL around it's
security through obscurity but that's me
eating lunch at 12 I went to Subway I
had 54 45 grams of carbs you can see the
the prediction line indicating what it
thinks might happen I'm on stage I might
have a low blood sugar I don't know you
can see my insulin on board that's
insulin that has not yet been absorbed
into my system you can see how many
carbs that I have left you see the
battery level all these things need to
be thought about is the battery about to
die on this on my pump is my blood sugar
decent over the last little while you
see this area here now it's blank
I had a battery died while I was
sleeping look at this area here what do
you see is the difference between the
data on the right and the data on the
left so the data in the left's very
noisy it's kind of yucky looking that
was the sensor starting to die the first
six to seven days are great and then
once you get into 10:15 you're
stretching the life of the sensors you
can start to get sloppy data and then
they die so these are all other things
that we have to think about as well
additionally there are somewhat
arbitrary limitations put on these
sensors by the companies these sensors
are rated for seven days we can restart
them and lie to them and say it's a
fresh day and they'll Reese we can
research in like 3-4 times but after 20
days it'll become a problem but these
are hundreds of dollars each so we've
even got
a community of people who dremeled these
open with a dremel tool and found out
that it's just to watch batteries so we
dremeled them open and then 3d print a
top this is a legitimate one this has
been dremeled open replaced the battery
and then epoxy did shut again and
that'll run for another three months
thereby enabling someone had not spend
seven or whatever this costs especially
for people in the US they don't have
insurance the NHS is a lot better than
what the situation we have right now
insulin in the US right now is three
hundred dollars a bottle I was told it's
between eight and twenty pounds here so
we have you know underground railroads
for lack of a better word of these
systems that are trying to get this
stuff out to the people
oops let me switch over to my slides oh
this this website also gives me a REST
API to my own blood sugar you can see
here the degrees of the slope the
current blood sugar so a buddy of mine
took that wrote a service that runs on
Windows that downloads that every five
minutes into a text file so now it's in
my get prompt
so as I'm working each time I hit enter
it doesn't call out it gets it from the
text file we as diabetics need these
glanceable displays I need to always
know what my blood sugar is I can't it's
not about notification it's about
knowing the trend
I can't yeah you can pop a notification
and tell me that I'm about to have a low
blood sugar but I'd like to know at ten
thousand feet and not at five hundred
feet so we've built in systems on
watches there's my blood sugar there
there's a chart and I've at we've added
it now just like three days ago I
rebuilt this watch and this is a
complication a series four complication
on the new watches that blood Sugar's
right there
so if I remember hanging out with you or
talking to you and you see me looking at
my phone or looking at my watch I'm not
trying to leave I'm just always always
thinking about what's going on with the
altitude otherwise I'm going to get
nailed but these are all systems that
are a combination of us breaking into
closed systems and using a closed system
so then move things to open systems so
for example this Dexcom device uploads
to the ver cloud and then we've kind of
sucked the data back out of their cloud
and put it into an open cloud that makes
sense
additionally we've discovered that we
can write small little devices create
small little devices and catch the data
in the air so we've got folks that have
sniffed Bluetooth Low Energy in the air
and as this transmitter goes and says
blood sugar every five minutes we catch
it with an Android phone or a small
device and then upload it so we
intercept that data right now my system
goes from here to my phone which is
around here somewhere right here and
then up to the cloud which is their
cloud and then back down to my own cloud
to my rest API it does run offline it
works just fine on an airplane but the
cloud connected scenario works a lot
better all of these are different
systems that are made to grab that data
as it runs by in the air and once you
have control
your own health data you can build cool
workflows you've all done things with
ifttt or Microsoft flow where it's like
if I tweet a picture put it in my
Dropbox I want to do things like you
know can i SMS someone my blood sugar or
put it in Google Calendar or download it
to Google Drive you think about your to
do's and your calendars and your inbox
and I think about all those things plus
blood sugar that's why it's in the get
prompt that's why it's in glanceable
displays right now in my house back in
Portland is a thing called a DAC board
which is a wall you can see all this in
my blog which is a wall mounted family
calendar with my blood sugar alongside
the family calendar and my wife
literally just texted me that she and
the boys were talking about if daddy's
having a low blood sugar what they
should do we've also got a vertically
mounted one it's got weather and blood
sugar on it as well because any rest API
allows me to do that that way my
diabetes management is a communal thing
as opposed to a lonely thing we've got
people who've taken pebbles pebble
pebble watches and smartwatches and put
things on top of them notice how they're
putting things together once that data
gets freed they're putting things
together now if I can read my sugar
values and I can think about what to do
about it how could I then close the loop
where it wouldn't be me that does that
dosing and how complicated would that be
well what would be needed if we were
gonna build one of these I would want to
read in what my current blood sugar is I
can do it from the REST API now or I can
grab it from the air and then I need to
write out to deliver insulin now there's
two ways to deliver insulin there is a
bolus and that's a medical term that
just means an infusion of liquid you can
go and if you're dehydrated they'll give
you a bolus of saline if you have a
bolus of insulin it means a large
infusion at one moment and then there's
basil which is background insulin the
gentleman with the pens has two
different pens he's got the morning pen
which is the background insulin for the
day it's basically a long slow acting
thing takes one shot and it go
for 12 hours or 24 hours and then
there's the breakfast lunch and dinner
bonuses one step would be to automate
the basil which is effectively making a
self-driving car that knows how to stand
the lines but just can't make dramatic
turns right it's like Tesla autopilot
isn't autopilot it's staying the lines
it doesn't stop at stoplights
it doesn't make sharp turns it just
stays no lies it's a cool cruise control
we could make cool diabetes cruise
control that would prevent nighttime low
blood sugars and floating away and
getting high without realizing it but it
wouldn't solve the mealtime issue but it
would be a good start however I need to
be able to remotely control a pump pumps
like this is a 15 year old pump we're
given in the 90s remote controls that
you put on your keychain so that you
could dose privately because people were
concerned about bothering other people
at the table with needles and stuff and
they didn't want to be ashamed they
would just go and they would count like
there's it's like a Morse code and I can
give myself insulin and then deliver it
I was canceling it right there and you'd
do it with a remote control so we
reverse engineered that that then you
know the people who are not me reverse
engineered that and found out that it's
running on nine hundred and fifteen
megahertz and the nine hundred megahertz
bandwidth which is the same as your
garage door opener and they figured out
how to go and do that but then a hacker
displayed that you could do that
maliciously if you knew someone's pump
serial number which kind of messed it up
for everybody which then caused the pump
companies to stop that so it only works
on a certain old firmware of that pump
or before so there's now a black market
for pumps where we have to go on
Craigslist or whatever and find the
certain pump that allows this because
they ruined it for us because there's
always some episode of law and order
where somebody has like walking down the
street and they got their instant pump
they go and then they die and then they
zoom up and then someone is like with
like a Pringles can and a computer and
the guy I just killed that guy remotely
because he had an insulin pump it would
not kill me it would give me a mediocre
afternoon it would kind of give his
screw-up my day and I sure in the hell
wouldn't fall on the ground but that's
the sense that they can kill hackers
from a mile away you know it just gets
bigger and bigger bigger yes it would
suck but no I'm not concerned that one
of you is gonna kill me
remotely I would probably I would
probably disconnect my pump and I would
look at it dripping and I would go
that's weird and then I would you know
walk away from you
it would be faster to just stab me so if
you want to kill me just stab me that's
what it is what the the thing is there
but so they ruined it for everybody so
now we can only use these pumps but we
figured it out but what's blocking us
continues to be this closed ecosystem
with no open standards no public SPECT
everything has been reverse-engineered
there was a gentleman who reverse
engineered how to get the data off of
Bluetooth myself and a gentleman named
Benjamin West reverse-engineered how to
break into the cloud with a
man-in-the-middle attack there is in
fact an ISO Bluetooth profile a standard
Bluetooth profile for pumps and blood
sugar meters that's not used you know
how you pair your headphones and your
phone goes oh hey headphones cool you
pair your car and your phone goes oh a
car should I sync your contacts is it
and it knows what to do
those are profiles of types of objects
there's no pumps that use bluetooth yet
even though the profile exists and very
very few pumps allow remote access for
security additionally we can't as an
open-source community start selling or
producing or creating this software and
giving it to you because what if you
kill somebody with it what if you kill
yourself or if you kill your kid so none
of this is saying that we are we are or
have packaged an open-source artificial
pancreas instead we have created
toolkits by which you could build one
from a reference design do you see the
subtle difference there you know how
we've all got like an uncle or an aunt
that has like a kit car that they built
or a motorcycle that they're working on
it's not street-legal but they built it
from a kit it's that kind of thing
because then when they kill themselves
driving that kit car you go was crazy
build his own car I mean would what are
you gonna do you can't access
we make an open-source pancreas you'd
have to really work over months to make
one of these we make it hard on purpose
there is this is a kind of a Cartesian
product of all the different things to
get your blood sugar meter in the cloud
because you have different brands
some people have Android some people
have iPhones some people want to run a
Heroku some people run azor all of these
different things the combination of the
watches the pumps the sensors some
things work some things don't
different brands different versions it's
a very challenging ecosystem if there
were standards it would not be if we
were going to close the loop we would
also need things like a place to store
your carbohydrates Apple health kit is
amazing for that you'd want to have
remote access to have be able to
remotely monitor someone if you send
your diabetic kid to school you'd love
to have their blood sugar on a watch
that would be amazing the nurse would
want to if a nurse at a school had five
or six kids they would want like a panel
of all the diabetic kids and see what
their blood sugar is we have that
ability now so what slowly been built up
by a bunch of genius people in the
community a little bit at a time our
Bluetooth library's Python pump
libraries various snippets of code
summon nodes summon C summon Python that
talks to pumps and different systems
that can then be put together into a
larger loop so this is a proposal for
the generations of what it would take to
close the loop the generation one would
be I detected you're going to have low
blood sugar like maybe you're passed out
I'm going to turn off the pump so as not
to make it worse that would be level one
that's not a very useful thing but if
you are low alot it'd be useful all the
way to the third generation would be a
multi hormone closed-loop fully
automated it would mean like oh you're
diabetic that sucks put this on your
body go eat cake somewhere in between is
where we are we're basically level four
we can automate the basal the background
we can basically keep you in the lines
but you have to dose at meals you have
to tell me about your meal
that's where we're at this is what we
would do to build a pancreas and Dana
Lewis is the kind of the godmother of
the open source pancreas community she
and her husband created the first
open-source artificial pancreas and it
was very clever there was a a
transmitter a receiver that talks to
this and you would go to the doctor and
you'd plug in a USB cable and you
download the data every three months she
got the idea well I mean it's just a PC
and a USB cable that says what's your
blood sugar we're doing it every three
months we could just do it in a loop
every five minutes so then she got a
Raspberry Pi and taped this to it with a
thing and wrote a loop get your blood
sugar get you blood sugar every five
minutes it drains the battery very fast
but it doesn't care whether it's three
months or every five minutes then she
saw that the doctor was talking to the
pump with a thing called a care link
which is a very specific doctor thing
that you can't find very much but she
got some on eBay
you plugged it into a Raspberry Pi and
that allows you to write to the pump and
then she would get a big battery like a
big and one of those big let's Hubble
pretend this as a battery get a big
battery like for your phone and she put
that in her in her we call it bum bag
and she carry her pack with her pancreas
about this big these are the components
the continuous meter the translator the
talks of the pump the pump itself a
battery in a Raspberry Pi it's a tiny
computer that's saying what's your blood
sugar what's your blood sugar which blur
and then it's running a loop it's
thinking about what you should do given
context and then it's talking to the
thing but that's that's a lot of crap to
carry around that's no fun so then we
talked to Intel they made a thing called
the Intel Edison it's a tiny little 486
looking thing it weighs nothing
3d printed case and you have an Edison
that runs Juby Linux just a little tiny
Linux runs node Python then you take a
lipo or a lithium poly ion battery you
stick it in there and you can run this
for about ten hours
in your pocket you just needed to get
that 900 megahertz transmitter because
Bluetooth is standard and Wi-Fi is
standard but we just need that
translator well we talked to sparkfun
and they make these little boards so you
take the 900 megahertz Explorer board
and you stack the Edison on top of it
and you put that sandwich into a 3d
printed case and then you have a little
pocket computer but it's got no screen
so you have to ssh into it or you use
the cloud to see what's going on but
that's cool and you keep that in your
pocket and then intel discontinued the
Edison so now we have a black market for
finding Edison so if you have an Intel
Edison no joke contact me and we will
donate it to someone who can use them
for a Pancras so then she's come up with
with her community the idea of taking a
Raspberry Pi zero and they made a custom
hat which is a sandwich that sits on top
of the Raspberry Pi with a tiny OLED
screen and two buttons and a battery and
that is now a pancreas completely
self-contained it is a it is the loop it
is the thing that closes the loop now
there are people though where'd my
swishy go there we go there are people
though who have said that that's
innovative and cool but that's a brain
and I'm carrying around a brain already
in my pocket I've got a pocket
supercomputer maybe my phone could be
the brain and this could be smaller
that's pretty small this gentleman here
Pete is an electrical engineer and his
child his name is Reilly and Pete said
well you know my phone has a CPU Wi-Fi
Bluetooth the only thing it's missing is
that 900 megahertz ability to talk to
the pump
so he made a link it's a Bluetooth to
900 megahertz bridge that makes my pump
my 15 year old non bluetooth enabled
pump
look like a Bluetooth object and then
the pancreas runs on the phone as a
background app now for many years we
would run this and the phones would you
know how iPhone just swipes away like
people like go like they swipe up their
apps to close them
iPhones would have memory pressure and
they would go yeah you're playing candy
crush I'm gonna shut your pancreas down
you know cuz you want to play don't play
candy crush you don't live there's
nothing that can run in the kernel
there's no hypervisor there's no like
this is an urgent important process
there's no way to say that on a an
iPhone but newer iPhones went from 201
gig to two gigs to four gigs they have
enough memory now that memory pressure
hasn't been a problem and you can run
these tiny little apps in the background
and the loop the background loop is like
30 or 40 Meg's so it stays around and
the iPhone does not usually toss it out
so now there is in fact a choice of
artificial pancreases
I can pick open APs which is entirely
self-contained that is a little computer
running on something like a Raspberry Pi
which gives me full control it's written
in Python a node and go I can I could
SSH into this pancreas and I could show
you the logs we've got a tiny little
screen with a tiny little graph and the
batteries last about 12 hours it's
pretty cool it has a very sophisticated
algorithm and they also have their
choice of algorithms so you can pick
your own algorithm or I could do loop
these are all raw brought all these for
you to look at later these are all riley
links that can bridge to the pumps and
then i'm gonna actually pull out the the
hdmi here and i'm gonna hook up my phone
how do i do that i'm gonna hook up my
phone here and i'm gonna plug it in i
can do this right
there we go okay this is my actual
pancreas you can see my pump right there
and I can see the signal there's Scots
Riley link and these are all basically
it's a REST API for the pump get pump
model read pump status discover commands
I can click on that and now it's talking
bluetooth to the small device which is
not a computer it's just a bridge over
to that nine hundred megahertz band
reading the pump status and it'll bring
back some JSON and then we can go and
write code against that it's very slow
there you go
33 units of insulin remaining the
battery's at almost a volt and a half it
is not currently delivering not
currently bola Singh okay if I want to
eat some food I can go in here and I can
use emoji what you laugh right but why
why would I want to do that because of
the glycemic index of food white rice
hits you faster than brown rice fruit
hits you faster than cheese this way I
can go and say look at the absorption
time when I put in cheese but the
absorption time if I put in fruit might
be less than that right let me start
over
so right now it's a three there's two
hours but if I add in some pizza now
it's four hours I can look at the
algorithm to decide about how to how
it's going to expect that curve to be
predicted this is current blood sugar
which is very good this is a prediction
line but look as it started to think I
was going to have a low on stage here it
turned off my pump at one forty one you
see that third line down there
I had one forty one it turned off the
pump and it hasn't been on since as it's
trying to land the plane smoothly and
then I can go and say well I'm gonna be
working out soon so I need you to run a
little higher so I'll have energy and
glucose so it's going to change that
target or I can say I'm going to eat
soon so I want you to bring it low
so that I can eat successfully and then
that green loop in the upper left-hand
corner there is telling me when the last
time it checked and figured out what was
going on and that sits on my desktop now
that has got me pretty much right in
between the two lines that I'm trying
into this is the road that I'm trying to
walk down trying to drive down rather
and it's keeping me in between those
lines pretty successfully I'm going to
switch back over to the PC there we go I
can also do it from the watch and we can
go and DOS from the watch as well
because I've got face ID or touch ID or
the fact that watches Apple watches lock
when they're taken off your wrist so
there's some security there as well
which is nice and it's all open source
with the goal being of course to die of
old age this is not fun this is a roller
coaster that's a high blood sugar that
can happen because I eat a cookie that
can happen because a couple of days ago
I was taking insulin and I had forgotten
to plug that in and it was in my pocket
and I got a pocket full of insulin
because I just was dosing I was pushing
a tin to me and I was like oh my pockets
all wet smells like band-aids and it was
insulin so I was like oh crap I ate
breakfast and did nothing that's where
you 400 I don't know what it is and
what's that what's what's horrible in in
this in metric 20s okay so if you're 20
or so you're Payton life yeah so three
four hundred you can't do that four more
in a couple weeks you'll be in the
hospital
this is swerving entirely off the road
and into the ditch all right we just
have different measurements now there is
a number do you use hemoglobin a1c here
and the UK okay so this is the number we
agree on which is not the short term
what's my blood sugar this moment but
what is my blood sugar been over the
last three months
it's a decaying average over three
months your blood sugar as the nor
is about four to six that says that this
and this is an oversimplification it's
like four or five percent of your red
blood cells are coated in sugar we'll
just say that that's about a
simplification numbers double that you
will die you cannot marinate in your own
sugar very long so we try to keep those
numbers as low as possible we want to
simulate being normal
most diabetics are just bouncing back
and forth between these numbers trying
to stay on the edge of normal when they
get their blood stuff their blood done I
spent many years at seven one seven and
a half this is my actual blood from my
doctor I am now five that means that if
you look on a blood panel a CBC or
complete blood panel it doesn't look
like I'm diabetic and I absolutely
attribute that to being super anal
retentive and uptight and type-a
personality and a artificial pancreas I
could not have flown here on Wednesday
arrived at noon talked at six o'clock at
a user group woke up fresh and hung out
with you all that just simply would not
be possible with with needles imagine
all those curves and all that stuff I
showed you then change time zones and
have Oprah let overlapping curves of
insulin taken in different time zones
and try to do that math it just wouldn't
been possible I couldn't have even flown
here and dealt with that to be a
diabetic is hard to be a diabetic
crossing time zones multiple times in a
week is virtually impossible it is this
system that makes that possible
and I'm very thankful for it so if we
agree that our data anywhere is a right
that it's my data and I want to get
access to my data that we want to
encourage the companies the pump makers
the sensor makers the blood sugar meter
makers to published specifications to
make rest api's to make libraries to
encourage us all to explore our data so
that we might go and do this to go and
make these now at some point probably
five years from now I'll be able to buy
one of these off the shelf that'll
probably great hopefully though then
the open-source community will have made
one that is five years in the future and
does other things I wouldn't recommend
this for the faint at heart but when you
say things someone might say well what
do you worry about security do you worry
about accuracy what about bugs it sucked
so bad before a couple of bugs a week
would still not keep me off this you
know what I'm saying and I usually hit
one or two a year and I report it and we
discuss it and it gets fixed like the
kinds of bugs you have just like the
assassination attempt that we talked
about will give you any horrible evening
but they will probably not put you in
the hospital so I've had time zone bugs
and oh I was off by a couple of units
and I had to get some sugar but it's so
much better just like people aren't
saying that Tesla autopilot or cruise
control should be removed because one or
two dumb people crashed into a parked
car right the state of diabetes
technology has improved I wrote an
article about it in 2012 if you want to
go and read on my blog in the diabetes
section I have a the sad state in 2012
and the promising state in 2018 and I
talked about the differences that six
years make as we start to move people
have created nonprofits like tidepool if
you're a diabetic you should check it
out if you have a friend who's a
diabetic it's a way for you to put all
of your data in one place that you
control and have API access to they have
a great uploader so just as I was
talking about making uploaders for
individual meters they've gone and done
the work for you and made up loaders to
get your data out of that the night
scout foundation that's the node
application that I showed you they are a
non-profit you can donate money you
could help them with their source code
you could improve the d3.js and the SVG
that we use to render the graphs all
kinds of stuff if you want to learn
about the code that actually runs the
open aps the artificial pancreas system
the code is up here for the reference
design and documentation on how you
could potentially build your own and
what hardware you would need this is a
little boy not mine going to school
for the first time with his artificial
pancreas and the parents are then able
to see it remotely and see that the
little boy is doing okay the hashtags to
check out our open aps and we are not
waiting thank you very much and I'm
gonna put all the pancreases and
equipment down here at the front for you
to come and check out thanks for
listening
[Applause]